>>Ian: Hello, and welcome to the Friday review
of games.
As always I'm your host.
Ian Ni-Lewis.
And with me today is our special guest Steven
Spielberg.
>>Dan: [laughs] Thank you very much.
Dan Galpin here as always to help out with
playing the games that you see here online.
And giving you guys a lot of great feedback.
Thanks a lot as always for nominating the
games to our Moderator.
And today we are gonna be doing driving games.
Which areó
>>Ian: Absolutely, driving games which are
actually some of my favorite games.
But I had never really played them on Android.
I played Fortza, the entire Fortza series
on my Xbox.
Actually started out with Project Gotham racing.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: Actually did some work on Project Gotham
Racing III.
Fixed their sound.
Well fixed the Xbox so it could play their
sounds.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: So love these games.
Lots of great titles.
But before we get started, wanted to make
some special mentions today.
In the studio with us we have our new engineer.
Engineer Dan.
>>Dan: Mm-hm.
>>Ian: The other Dan.
Dan Fam.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: and producer Reto Meier.
So can you introduce yourselves guys.
>>Dan F: Hey you guys.
This is Daniel Fam.
Just wanted to say hi.
>>Reto: And this is Reto.
And you may know me better from the Android
App clinic.
Which is on immediately before.
And I'll be keeping an eye on all of the live
streams and hopefully passing any questions
you have straight on to the guys behind the
desk.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
Now let's see the producer cam.
>>Dan G: That was the idea.
It's to show the producer cam.
Alright.
>>Ian: We got the producer cam guys?
>>Reto: hit Hangout.
On the loweró
>>Dan G: Ah, there we are.
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Reto: Second from the top--
>>Ian: There you go.
>>Reto: No, not that one.
No
>>Dan G: No, we're getting good though.
Absolutely.
Awesome.
>>Reto: Try it again.
[laughter]
>>Ian: That's not it either.
But.
Oh, oh oh, now, yah, yah.
One more step.
There we go.
>>Reto: Hi!
>>Dan G: Alright.
>>Ian: Alright.
>>Dan G: Producer cam.
Excellent.
>>Ian: Whoo-hoo!
Everybody was complaining.
They said why don't you hire a professional.
And we did.
So you can just stop complaining now.
From now on the show's gonna be great.
>>Dan G: That's right.
It's gonna suck less.
I really like that like that.
>>Ian: Alright.
So as far as sucking less goes, why don't
we go ahead and open up some liquid humor.
>>Dan G: [laughs] Oh wow, this is a big bottle.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Well, you know it is a double chocolate stout.
So today we're drinking Irondale Double Chocolate
Stout.
From, uh, I have no idea actually.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: Swanton Rea's.
Apparently.
>>Dan G: Yeah, brewed in bottle by Hermitage
Brewing Company in San Jose.
So there we are.
>>Ian: Beautiful.
So this is local.
>>Dan G: Yeah, that's fantastic.
>>Ian: Even though it's got a label, it's
all like, I don't know, English-y or something.
>>Dan G: Absolutely.
>>Ian: Whoa.
Well, well.
>>Dan G: Exactly.
There we are.
>>Ian: There you go.
>>Dan G: Excellent.
Thank you sir.
[bottle cap clinks]
>>Ian: Alright, although apparently we are
limited in the amount of time we can show
what we're drinking.
Because after a few number of seconds.
The Man considers it a beer commercial.
[laughter]
>>Dan G: I'm still wondering who The Man is.
>>Ian: Well in this case the man is our boss
Billy.
Hi Billy!
>>Dan G: Hi Billy.
>>Ian: So alright.
Let's go ahead and talk about some games.
Who do you wanna look at first Dan?
>>Dan G: Alright well I've got two games cued
up here.
We're actually gonna try a little bit of a
different tack this time.
We have two Transformer Prime's rather than
one.
And the first game I wanted to look at was
Real Racing.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
Whoa.
You're, I mean you're really, you're gonna
make it hard for anybody to follow this, OK?
>>Dan G: I know.
I know.
This game is awesome.
I mean.
>>Ian: OK, let's go ahead and take a look
at it.
>>Dan G: Let's do one.
Let's do Courier.
I'm gonna do easy.
>>Ian: Alright.
>>Dan G: "Are you sure you wanna do easy?"
Yes.
>>Ian: Very easy.
OK.
>>Dan G: Let's bring up the camera on that.
So here we are with Real Racing and we'll
start off with our club division.
This is exactly how you begin the game.
And Real Racing is from Firemint Studios down
in Australia.
And they really have I think set the bar for
realistic graphics on a racing game.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan F: Camera two.
>>Dan G: And alright, we hit the home key.
>>Ian: Nice.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: Well let's see how they recover from
that.
>>Dan G: Exactly.
>>Ian: See, that was totally planned.
>>Dan G: That was our first test.
Right.
Exactly.
Or it's possible that it died.
Hopefully.
Oh.
Come on.
Fingers crossed.
That's what's great about doing a live program.
[sucks in breath] Ooooohhh.
Man.
Alright, so first thing.
>>Ian: OK, So.
>>Dan G: Checking the license every single
time you run.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan G: Oh.
Sad.
>>Ian: You might also do that.
And the main reason is because you might be
somewhere where you can't get network connectivity.
So have a license policy that lets you check
the license intermittently.
And if you don't get it, if you don't get
a contact with the license server for a couple
times, it's not a big deal.
Most people aren't gonna be able to contact
the license server every single time they
play.
>>Dan G: Yeah, the server manager that we
have built into you know the license servers.
That's the way to go.
It, you know we actually think that it makes
a lot of sense.
That people can still get their license and
yet play the game on a plane or something
like that.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan G: Let's try a quick race instead.
Let's see how we do.
>>Ian: Sure.
Go easy on the camera two there, hot shot.
>>Dan G: [laughs] Exactly.
So and now we're at the exciting loading screen
agaaaaaain.
>>Ian: I love this loading screen man.
But you know, but look at this.
It's cool.
I mean, obviously you know, you're always
gonna have constraints with a mobile device.
Mobile devices have power and heat and battery
and size constraints that a full console or
desktop computer don't have.
But with all that considered, its' a really
nice looking game, I mean they've done all
of the interstitials and the hide and everything.
Just like I remember on my Xbox.
It's great stuff.
>>Dan G: And you can actually, one thing that's
not easy to figure out is you can actually
change the view here.
And you'll notice, you know you actually would
think that you would get a higher frame rate
when the full HUD was up.
But actually you don't.
Andó
>>Ian: Yeah, show that again.
>>Dan G: Yeah, here's our different views.
Here's our full screen.
There's our front.
And there's with the.
>>Ian: and what's the problem here, Dan?
Whyó
>>Dan G: And the theory that I have, and I
haven't thrown this one through all of my
tools.
Is that in fact if you notice the out, the
border of the HUD actually has some translucency
on it.
You can see the outside of those windows.
And so my theory is that they're actually
drawing this HUD last in order to get that
a little bit of transparency.
And what they probably should be doing is
drawing just the translucent parts of the
HUD last.
And actually drawing the rest of the HUD first.
'cause you'll actually see the frame rate
is just killer when it's not there.
>>Ian: Right, they probably can't see it.
Because I don't think we can capture video
for YouTube
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: At the highest frame rate this device
can put out.
But take it, take Dan's word for it.
Because Dan has sort of a fifth sense when
it comes to frame rate.
>>Dan G: [laughs] No, it looks amazing.
And actually I've found that I really love
playing it this way.
I actually get a sense of speed playing at
full screen without the HUD.
>>Ian: Yeah, that's some nice texture down
there.
>>Dan G: Yeah, it's beautiful.
You can even see on the road, what I love
is that they're using a beautiful job with
filtering there.
And you can see MIT mapping.
That texture is just beautifully mit mapped
so that when it's close it does not look blurry
and when it's far away it is not clogging
down the GP with lots of extra drawing.
And so you know, I mean this really is just
kind of a boiler plate of how to put the game.
Even when you see these buildings that we
pass by.
The textures might be a slightly bit blurrier
but we have such a great feeling of speed
and the frame rate is high enough that we
donít' even notice it.
And even little things like the effects of
the sun flaring on the windshield.
I mean it's just beautifully, beautifully
done.
And the, the other optimizations or changes
you can make are pretty simple.
You can turn on and off the HUD if you wanna
have just, be that much more immersive.
Now it's interesting, this game actually does
not have a back button on the screen.
Which is awesome.
You actually have to hit the back key to get
here.
And you can actually go and change in the
settings to go and say that I don't want to
have the heads up display.
And now we can actually go back.
And again it's all driven using the standard
Android navigation system which is cool.
And so now there we have, we're really just
full screen which is kind of awesome.
Like just being able to get to this view I
think is supper killer.
The other thing is that they don't have an
accelerator.
All we can do is brake.
We brake by tapping the screen.
And it is actuallyó
>>Ian: You can actually put it into a mode
where you need to both accelerate and brake.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: Which can be nice actually.
I prefer it that way because I like to slide
around corners
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: By just decelerating a bit.
But I think they made the right choice as
far as making it easy to jump in and play.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: There's a lot of assists on.
Which is why Dan is doing so well.
>>Dan G: [chuckles] Yes.
I'm in easy mode.
>>Ian: Why don't you play this game with the
assists off?
Show 'em what it feels like.
>>Dan G: OK.
>>Ian: Uh, just go into your settings andó
>>Dan G: OK, let's get back into settings.
Dah.
And under, uhó
>>Ian: Settings.
Yeah.
>>Dan G: So I can't change to "difficult"
from here.
I'd have to restart.
>>Ian: Oh, you'd have to restart the race.
>>Dan G: Yeah, exactly.
So that was what I was afraid of.
But yeah, the game really just have a great
sliding scale.
But if you wanna just jump into it it's great
too.
There's nothing that prevents you.
And again as you're looking at this freeze
frame you can just see how high quality that
road texture is.
>>Ian: yeah, let me take a look at that actually.
So this is, um, like you really see what'só
>>Dan G: Yeah, the MIT mapping right there
in the center of the screen.
>>Ian: Well, what's really amazing is that
they've actually done a good job of simulating
an ISO.
>>Dan G: yes.
>>Ian: I don't think they're actually doing
an ISO 'cause I don't think this hardware
can do it at that level.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: For a lot of MIT map stuff you'll actually
see sort of a line you know, about, let's
say an inch from the bottom of the screen
you'd actually see it turn really blurry.
Or get some you know, just visual artifacts
and general other [inaudible]
>>Dan G: Hm.
The attention to detail is awesome on this
game.
So yeah, so this game also was originally
released as essentially a free demo that was
unlockable.
And this version is now the premium version.
And it's totally worth it.
For 99 cents it's an absolute steal.
And if you like racing this game really does
have the best visceral feel I think of any
racing game.
>>Ian: Yeah, so really I think the only thing
we're saying about it is, if you're going
to paste a big ass HUD on your screen [Dan
chuckles] do it first so that these parts
can z-reject pretty fast.
>>Dan G: Mm-hm.
>>Ian: And there are no mobile chips that
are really good at overdraw.
No Android GPU is going to be happy with tons
and tons of overdraw.
So just don't do it.
The one thing that I'm missing in this game
and, it's actually in every game that we've
looked at.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: I'm really missing good damage.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: And I don't see why not.
I think the hardware is perfectly capable
of running a damage model.
A simple one.
I'm actually because nobody has it, especially
the two Gameloft games I'm looking at, I'm
actually wondering if they couldn't get the
license.
>>Dan G: Well that's what I was wondering
too.
You have to get a specialó
>>Ian: Yeah, damage license.
So that is, yeah.
>>Dan G: But real cars in this game are beautifully
rendered.
It's again, it is the real car game, the real
car racing game on Android.
>>Ian: Yeah, and it is tough.
>>Dan G: It is tough.
Especially if you're in easy mode.
But it is nice the easy mode for people who
just wanna drive.
So I'm going to switch over.
>>Ian: Yeah, as a contrast.
This one, I would call this next one, "Forza
III meets Mario Kart".
>>Dan G: [laughs] So we're now looking at
Asphalt 7.
Let's, and I switched the tablets so we can
make a very very very fast switch.
These are big big games.
>>Ian: Whoo!
>>Dan G: So I'm gonna let Ian play on this
one.
>>Ian: Oh, ok you're gonna cue up the next
one?
>>Dan G: Yeah, I'm gonna cue up the next one.
>>Ian: OK.
So for this one, the game mechanics are similar
in a lot of ways and since we're, it's another
one of these games where you start with a
little bit of money.
And that's gonna let you buy a car.
And then you're gonna compete in races for
more cars and more upgrades and things like
that.
>>Dan G: There we are.
We've switched.
Now we're really on Asphalt 7: Heat. [laughs]
>>Ian: Nice.
Alright.
>>Dan G: So, yeah.
And so this is using, is what is not a free
title.
This is a paid title.
But it's a 99 cent title as well.
And it's, it is very playable without additional
purchases.
But it does strongly encourage you to spend
additional money on the game.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Well, you're gonna grind a lot to get more
stars.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: And in fact you're gonna pay a lot
to get more stars too.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: So I noticed, for instance, so the
first thing you get which is your little tiny
Fiat Abarth?
I guess.
I don't actually know how to say that.
But this is like the entry level car for every
racing game ever.
[Dan laughs] You wanna go up a level.
To a range rover.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: Or even just a Mini Cooper S. That's
gonna cost you 30 stars.
Now 30 stars is like ten or 15 bucks actually
in there.
>>Dan G: is it really?
Wow.
>>Ian: It's quite a lot.
Let's see.
Get more stars.
Um, yeah, yep, there you go, ten bucks.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: Or you get one or two stars per race.
>>Dan G: Mm.
>>Ian: So you can see, you're gonna grind
a lot in this game.
I mean, these are not cheap.
So but you know, aside from that it's actually
really fun.
The races themselves are a good time.
I'm gonna go andó
>>Dan G: Mm. and you know to be honest, as
long as you can grind in the game, I think
it's actually kinda fun and does give it sort
of an RPG element.
And I think that's actually kind of a not
entirely a bad thing.
In terms of this.
>>Ian: yeah.
And you've got this interesting thing where
you like pay 5,000 for a sponsor.
Which is a little weird 'cause I thought the
sponsor would pay you.
>>Dan G: I pay you, I know.
[laughs]
>>Ian: OK, fine.
They've got some goals here.
They've got a little bit of a style system.
Like Project Gotham used to have.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: Where you get some extra points for
doing things like drifting and getting air.
[pause]
Mmm.
And they also have some really beautiful interstitials.
>>Dan G: They absolutely do.
>>Ian: Yeah, it's very professional.
It's exactly the kinda thing you'd expect.
Now once again, this is a very simple game.
I think it is an auto accelerator.
You have to, if you wanna brake you have to
hit the screen.
But they have a nitro bonus system.
Because of course they do right?
>>Dan G: Yeah, which is that's the Mario Kart
element.
And actually just to point out there are many
many control schemes for Asphalt 7.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan G: So you can use tap on the screen.
You can use Virtual Wheel.
There's just tons and tons of different ways
you can set youró
>>Ian: Yeah.
You control.
But I tell you, especially with the newer
Android tablets having a significant improvement
in--Whoa!
>>Dan G: Nice.
Air.
>>Ian: Significantly improved their gyroscope
and accelerometers, so you can get the attitude
sensor to work really really well.
>>Dan G: Now I'll tell you a couple things
about this games.
One of them is, this game actually has shortcuts
in the races.
Which are totally fun, there's a lot of stuff
to find.
There's far more than just one route through
any of the individual races.
My only complaints about this game are really
that, you'll see that if you look at the quality
of it, if you hit the pause key actually so
we can take a look at one of these frames.
>>Ian: Oh.
>>Dan G: you can't actually look at the frame
I guess.
>>Ian: Can you pause?
>>Dan G: I guess you can't.
I thought you could.
Anyways.
>>Ian: Oh, here we go.
>>Dan G: No.
No.
>>Ian: No, you can't just pause.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
Anyway, you can see if you look down, the
quality of the road just is not anywhere near
what Real Racing is putting out.
And if you look at the vegetation going by.
You can see that the stuff that's near the
camera is really really pixilated.
>>Ian: Right.
But you never notice that because you're going
too damn fast.
>>Dan G: Right.
Exactly.
Also from a frame rate perspective.
>>Ian: [shouting at game]
>>Dan G: it is not, we're not getting consistently
high frame rates.
It's pretty good.
I mean, this is definitely, but I think that
there's aó
>>Ian: It doesn't bother me.
And actually if you play it on, like I played
it on the Nexus 7, I never noticed a frame
rate problem at all.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: Of course, I don't have your supernatural
skill in judging frame rates.
>>Dan G: So it is interesting.
So this one I did actually throw into perf
HUD to take a look at it.
And I was actually going to do sort of an
interactive perf HUD view on the show today
but I think tható
>>Ian: No, but Dan chickened out.
Trying toó
>>Dan G: I did.
I chickened out.
But partially because it wasn't interesting
enough with this sort of game play.
But I, one thing that is interesting is you'll,
on this game you'll notice the cars are drawn
last.
And so we areó
>>Ian: Yeah.
Um. [inaudible]
>>Dan G: Which is a little unfortunate cause
it is taking up a large chunk of the screen.
>>Ian: Well, for the player's car.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: You'd probably wanna draw the other
things last, well, of course.
This is something that is, oh yeah, check
it out.
I'm in adrenaline mode!
>>Dan G: Aaaaaaa!
>>Ian: Who!
Knock down!
>>Dan G: So.
>>Ian: So adrenaline mode is like you're in
Tron mode.
You can do no wrong.
It's awesome.
I have no idea how I even got there.
>>Dan G: [chuckles]
>>Ian: Ooooh.
Wrecked.
Now see that's my problem.
I just wrecked.
My car is completely smashed up.
But it looks perfect.
Why?
Did Fiat make you do that?
>>Dan G: [chuckles] It's very possible.
Um.
>>Ian: So, the yeah.
In generally what you wanna do is draw your
foreground elements first.
So that you can take advantage of hierarchical
z.
And in this case what you probably wanna do,
you know for a racing game, is you can assume
that the players car is always gonna be in
the foreground.
Anything else is probably not worth it.
The other cars are almost never in the foreground.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
You really see when you see the vegetation
on the left hand side of the screen where
we're going now.
That's where you really see the quality.
>>Ian: Yeah, I think that's a textural density
issue.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: They just aren't loading up big enough
textures.
Um, although, you know, they have a lot of
varied textures.
>>Dan G: They do.
>>Ian: and for the areas of the track that
are father away it's actually very well done.
I think.
>>Dan G: Yes.
Absolutely.
I just think there's probably one level of
MIT mapping that's missing.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan G: And tható
>>Ian: Well and knowing the game development
process I wouldn't be surprised if that level
was created and then thrown away at the last
minute in order toó
>>Dan G: Yeah.
Very possible and you can also see there is
a bit of popup going on.
If you look at that in the distance.
And--
>>Ian: yeah, I did notice some popup.
And that's an issue.
And it's actually a little bit surprising
considering for instance, this particular
GPU is really excellent at geometry.
>>Dan G: yes.
>>Ian: compared to its pixel performance.
You actually probably get more out of pushing
your far z plane out a little bit but you
know.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
When youó
>>Ian: That's not gonna be the right choice
for everyone.
>>Dan G: And also that is only good if you're
drawing in the reverse draw.
If you're drawing in order you're going to,
by pushing your z plane out you're still gonna
have some pretty big performance problems.
>>Ian: Well, if you're going back to front.
Right.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
If you're going, if you're goingó
>>Ian: Which you should never do.
Right?
I mean.
>>Dan G: Exactly.
>>Ian: I mean drawing your stuff back to front
is always the wrong choice unless you have
to do Alpha.
What you should be doing is just like these
guys here is you should be drawing that alpha
area last.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
Absolutely.
So that's just basically something that everyone
needs to look at.
That being said, this game is totally fun.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Dan G: And that's, and it is beautiful looking.
>>Ian: It's a kick.
Andó
>>Dan G: I just wanna see it that much better.
Like that's--
>>Ian: Yeah.
I really do too.
And I would love to see more you know, some
more collisions.
Some more particles.
My guess is that the very top end of Android
devices, especially tablets could handle more
than what we're seeing here.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: I would love, I would pay extra to
get let's say a Tegra optimized version or
this.
Or a tablet optimized version of this.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
>>Ian: To play around with 'cause I think
this game could be even cooler than it is.
>>Dan G: Totally.
Totally.
And you know.
Just interestingly enough, hitting the back
key multiple times just gets us out to the
menu.
Kind of the way we'd like.
They've done a good job of making the navigationó
>>Ian: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, the navigation is great.
>>Dan G: And boom, we're back out.
>>Ian: Perfect.
>>Dan G: So that's that.
Let me see, I was gonna try to cue up the
next game on this tablet.
And we'll see if I actually managed to do
that.
>>Ian: OK.
Before we start the next game I think Producer
Reto has something to say.
>>Dan G: Oh, exactly.
He is on the screen.
So.
>>Reto: Exactly.
Thanks guys.
So just a couple comments on YouTube and on
the G plus stream.
So Leif points out that Asphalt 7 does notification
spam, and after not playing it for a few days.
>>Dan G: Ooooh.
>>Ian: Oh.
How many people don't do notification spam?
>>Dan G: Now the real question is actually
whether or not you can actually turn off notifications?
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan G: And right away Game Loft assures
me that it's actually, the game is intended
to be playable offline.
If for some reason, you saw that network errors
occur, we tried cancel.
They say that's a bug.
>>Ian: So what we're asking people to do now
is, OK, we understand that some people like
notifications.
We don't know who those people are, but apparently
some people do like notifications.
What we want to do is make sure that users
who don't want notifications or even users
who do want notifications but they don't want
all of them, have the ability to control that.
Now of course we added new features to Jellybean
to make it easier to control the kinds of
notifications that you get from different
apps.
But that's sort of an all or nothing thing.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
>>Ian: You can say "This app is never allowed
to make, to send me notifications" or "This
app is allowed."
Now me personally, I don't mind being told
for instance that there is a massive sale
on some in-app item of a game I like.
But I do hate personally, I do hate those
notifications that are like "You haven't played
me in a while.
Why don't you come back?"
I mean.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: If I wanted somebody whining at me
about coming to play, I'd play GTA4.
[laughter]
>>Dan G: Yeah, no exactly.
And actually one of the things I was looking
for, and I didn't actually check this game
before we started.
And I was looking to see if there was a way
to disable that within the game.
Doesn't look like there is.
We strongly encourage developers to make that
something they can turn off.
And 'cause a lot of users prefer it.
Now it's interesting, on one of the other
Game Loft games if you turn off notifications,
every single time you start up the game it
pops up a dialog and says "Hey, you realize
you've turned off notifications?
Would you like to turn them on?"
>>Ian: Wow.
That's like iTunes bad.
"Hey I noticed I'm not your default game player
for this machine?
Would you like to change that?"
>>Dan G: Yeah.
[chuckles]
>>Ian: Come on.
>>Dan G: So.
>>Ian: There will come a day when a, those
people will be the first up against the wall.
But even before that there will come a day
when that is no longer considered feature-worthy.
>>Dan G: Yeah, we really wanna make sure the
user experience is, and addressing the user
concerns are the number one priority for developers.
And you know, we understand that notifications
are useful.
There's a lot of game players who actually
really like them.
And certainly on a lot of the games or resource
management is an issue.
Or their daily bonuses.
That's really awesome.
You know like, playing Dungeon Hunter and
going "Hey man, there's like if I play today
I have an opportunity to get 5,000 gold for
doing this."
That's kinda cool as long as I can turn it
off.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan G: Well we do have the other game, do
you wanna go on?
Or are there other questions.
>>Ian: Reto maybe had one more question.
>>Reto: There is, there's one more.
So this is an actual question, a programming
question from Alex.
>>Dan G: Right.
OK.
>>Reto: On G plus stream.
And he says "You guys always say to pay attention
to the resolution of the art aspects within
games so that they don't look blurry or overstretched."
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm
>>Reto: "I'd like to know what you think of
pixel art style of graphics.
Do you think it's ok to do all the art on
a canvas of say 400 by 240 height with pixel
art style?"
He's asking because pixel art looks nice when
stretched but it's all messed up when shrunken.
And that goes against standard best practices
on game art where you obviously have higher
res assets and then shrink them down.
Although making two separate groups of the
artwork both big and small seems to be a better
option it's not practical 'cause it's going
to take too many resources.
>>Ian: Well, remember that the reason it looks
bad when it' shrunk is because we're doing
the scaling very quickly.
And it's usually, for instance OpenGL just
implements a bi-linear filtering which isn't
very good.
Now, if you run your art through something
like Photoshop and it does a Lanczos filter
on it, you're gonna get art that looks pretty
much great.
>>Dan G: yeah, exactly.
I wouldn't worry too much about that.
You also actually can actually go into bitmap
factory you can set the options for higher
quality scaling as well.
Within the actually scaling of the bitmaps
and that.
That may help you out as well.
But the truth is, yeah, my feeling is high
resolution pixel art looks amazing.
>>Ian: Mm-hmm.
>>Dan G: And the games we saw, if you looked
at the last weeks show we were doing tower
defense games.
We saw some amazing high res pixel art.
That just, that looked mind blowingly good
on these devices and actually scale down reasonably
well.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan G: So I think it comes down to art design
and style.
There definitely are outlying pixel art really
doesn't scale very well.
If you're trying to have lots and lots of
really delicate line details, those are gonna
get lost alot of the time.
>>Ian: Yeah.
You need to do that.
>>Dan G: But it reallyó
>>Ian: Well, and you know who does actually
very careful line drawing?
Is Rovio.
>>Dan G: Mm-hmm.
Absolutely.
>>Ian: and they actually put a lot of effort
into making sure that at every single resolution
the blackout line around the birds is exactly
one pixel wide.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
And they're very good about that.
And so I think it's certainly possible.
It's more of an art design question I think
than a technical question when it comes to
that.
>>Ian: I think a lot of people will do something
in pixel art thinking that's actually gonna
be easier.
And it's not.
Doing pixel art well and making it look great
on a modern device and also appealing to modern
users is actually really tough.
Because you want it to be old school but you
don't actually want it.
>>Dan G: Actually want itó
>>Ian: To be old school.
You want it to be evocative rather than representative
of your limitations.
>>Dan G: Absolutely.
But I mean we certainly love pixel art.
We've given major thumbs up to a lot of pixel
art titles in terms of you know what we, the
presentation.
And I think the real key thing is just again,
like anything else, it all depends on the
quality of your artist as much as anything
else.
And your design.
Andó
>>Ian: Absolutely.
So.
Producer Reto, I have to ask, was, so is that
HPC2000 guy on the live chat?
>>Reto: I haven't seen any questions from
him yet.
>>Ian: OK.
Yeah, he was gonna ask you a question about
open gl.
I told him I'd answer it.
But I'm not gonna answer it if he's not watching.
'Cause come on.
>>Reto: Exactly.
I will keep an eye out.
I will let you know if he is actually here.
>>Ian: Sounds good.
Let's go ahead and move to our next game.
>>Dan G: Alright, so our next game isn't really
a driving game.
It would be aó
>>Ian: Is there driving in this game?
>>Dan G: There is driving.
>>Ian: There is a lot of driving in this game.
>>Dan G: It isn't really a racing game.
I should say.
>>Ian: That's true.
We didn't say racing.
>>Dan G: It is a driving game.
>>Ian: we said "driving."
>>Dan G: Did we?
>>Ian: Yes.
>>Dan G: OK.
>>Ian: And the only thing that we put off
limits was golf, as I recall.
>>Dan G: That's true.
We said that it was not that kind of driving.
[laughs] So here we are.
It is GTA.
They've done a great job of bringing it to
Android.
It controls very very well.
I actually really like the fact that the default
set of controls is actually tapping the screen.
Rather than accelerometer.
I think it works really well for the kind
of arcade-y style of driving that is in the
game.
And so you know, since it is a driving game
we're doing to hit the car.
Now there are a lot of on screen buttons in
this game.
And I would say a lot of that is because it
wasn't really designed for this kind of system.
I think if you were designing it today, you
would not have nearly as many button actions
as this game has.
>>Ian: Yeah, this is definitely more of a
port than a remix.
I think it's not reallyó
>>Dan: Wow, am I driving badly.
>>Ian: It's not really re-imagined for tablet,
it's just totally ported.
So you know what this plays awesomely with
is like a Nyko controller or an Xbox 360 controller.
Plug into the USB port.
>>Dan: And it's great, this port that if you're
on an Android 3.x device or you're on something
like the Xperia Play 3.x or higher device
they really do a great job of making sure
those are there for you guys.
But other than that they did a very good job
of porting the game and the graphics over.
>>Ian: You know where I played this is, I
met with the Wikipad guys.
>>Dan G: Oh yeah.
>>Ian: You might have seen Wikipad online.
They were at GDC.
And they handed me a prototype and it was
playing GTA three and I'm like, wow.
It's a completely new experience to be able
to play that on tablet with a controller that's
built in.
Do I'm hoping that we see more of those.
And there's several that, Wikipad, Nyko's,
there's one other I can't remember.
>>Dan G: Yeah, Moga is also doing it.
>>Ian: Moga.
>>Dan G: Yeah, it's got a pretty cool controller
andó
>>Ian: And of course we support USB controllers.
Basically any USB controller that Linux supports.
>>Dan G: Yeah and Bluetooth as well.
So USB and Bluetooth controllers.
You know, there's really gonna be a lot of
choice out there.
Let's run into a few more trees here in Grand
Theft Auto.
So what we're gonna say about this other than
it's a port done well.
I would love to see a more native version
designed for touch controls.
I think that you could take it really really
far.
But they've done about as good a job as you'd
expect to do given where they started with
a fairly complicated joystick interface.
Nice, my car is on fire.
And Iím in the first, I'm in training mission.
Um.
>>Ian: This is just, it's a fun game.
What more to say?
>>Dan G: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: Let's not waste any more time.
They did a good job.
Oh, but there is actually one thing that's
unique about this game.
>>Dan G: Um-hm.
>>Ian: If they still have it.
They still have the persistent notification?
>>Dan G: Yes.
They do, they just kind of whack you with
that.
So if we go to the home screen you'll see
that it actually lets you know whether it's
still running and allows you to get back to
the game right away.
I don't know how exactly I feel about this.
'Cause things do run in the background and
that's the expectation.
>>Ian: I know, I know, I am so torn about
this.
Because on the one hand, it violates a lot
of the philosophy that we have around Android.
On the other hand, it's done for such a good
reason.
Because basically everything that we've done
around Android is for a completely different
use case.
>>Dan G: Yes.
Andó
>>Ian: and the use case of having something
that is really really big, and really really
expensive to initialize, but also something
that you might wanna interrupt every now and
then to let's say, get a phone call.
It's tough.
So they've done something interesting.
They basically say, OK we're gonna run all
the time.
But instead of just doing that, which is horrible,
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: They put up a persistent notification
that says essentiallyó
>>Dan G: Our process is still in memory.
>>Ian: Yeah.
GTA III is sitting here taking up resources
and draining resources so you can go back
to it fast.
Do you want it to stop that?
>>Dan G: It is, yeah.
It is actually not draining your battery.
But it is still resident in memory.
>>Ian: Mm.
Well.
>>Dan G: So it doesn't actually keep the game
running.
The threads areó
>>Ian: The threads are stopped.
But it will end up making things harder for
you.
You know, there will be more swapping out.
>>Dan G: Yeah, I mean ultimately Android will
kill the process if you try to run too much
stuff.
And we should actually just try that.
Let's try to launch Real Racing and see what
happens.
Now I'm, testing fade here.
We're obviously running two enormous titles.
What should happen is we should see GTA get
kicked out of memory.
Always gonna do these things live.
[chuckles]
>>Ian: Let's see what happens.
>>Dan G: Exactly.
>>Ian: Well my point is that it's not consuming
CPU, but it is gonna consume the battery because
what's gonna happen is that small wraps are
gonna cycle in and out faster.
>>Dan G: Yes.
And the thing is, once it gets kicked out
it should just be kicked out.
It doesn't get kicked back in unless they're
actually running a service.
And hopefully they're not doing that.
>>Ian: Well they are running a service.
They've got a persistent notification, it's
really hard to tell.
>>Dan g: yeah, I actuallyó
>>Ian: You're gonna have to go out of here
and then go back into GTA and see what the
[inaudible]
>>Dan g: Yeah, well you see the notification
is still there.
So it'só
>>Ian: well that's true but that doesn't really
mean anything 'cause all that means is their
service is still alive.
It doesn't necessarily mean their main processor
is.
>>Dan g: Yeah, let's take a look at what happens.
Boom.
There we are.
>>Ian: Wow.
Well you know.
>>Dan G: So we had, this takes a lot of ram.
[laughs] So.
>>Ian: well that's true.
>>Dan G: And anyways, again it is possible
to swap between two rather large games.
I donít think I wanna push it and actually
swap between more than that.
But there we are with Real Racing as well.
So.
Awesome.
Nice multitasking going on there.
>>Reto: Couple of quick points from YouTube.
Crispy Core wants to know if you can try and
see if the tilt controls work while driving.
He asked that just a couple of minutes ago
so I'm guessing that's for GTA.
>>Dan g: The tilt controls for GTA?
>>Reto: There seems to be a lot of problems
with that.
>>Dan g: I think there may be an issue and
as I recall this is one of those games that
actually has I think accelerometer issues.
So let's turn accelerometer on.
And let's use take analog.
>>Ian: Use analog steering yeah.
>>Dan g: Analog steering.
>>Ian: And turn that on.
OK.
>>Dan g: OK.
And lets' take a look.
As I recall, this may have been one of those
games that actually does not correctly, we
look at the default orientation when interpreting
the accelerometer.
But I think as I recall, and it's been a while,
I think they do it correctly for tablets.
And they may not do it correctly for--.
>>Ian: so that may actually be something the
type of device instead ofóso what'll happen
is the orientation is always done with respect
to a default orientation of the device.
You know, in other words, which orientation
the home screen expects to display in. and
that's not always what the game expects.
Ironically, this isn't very difficult to deal
with.
Where people get into trouble is when they
try to figure out what the default orientation
is.
And then figure out what the accelerometer
is telling them rather than just believing
the quaternion they can get from the accelerometer.
>>Dan g: Yeah, the quaternion is actually
always going to be correct.
And that's really the key here.
But anyway, the tilt is working fine here.
We should try it on a phone device and see
whether it's also handling that correctly.
I shouldn't say phone.
What I should say is a portrait default device.
The real question is what happens on Nexus
7 here.
So we can, I think I have it on this guy.
>>Ian: We'll cue that up and see if there's
another question while we're doing that.
>>Reto: Exactly, so while Dan's getting that
going, HPC2000 is in fact here, so we would
love to hear the answer to his question.
So if you could repeat the question.
>>Ian: Right.
I believe the question was about how, oh,
boo.
>>Dan g: Whoa.
>>Ian: Look at that.
I downloaded all these files last night.
At least I thought I did.
Maybe I didn't.
HPC2000 asked, how easy is it to take an open
GLES game that's made for some other system.
He named a system, I hadn't heard of it.
>>Dan g: yeah.
>>Ian: But whatever, use what you want.
If you wanna port from another system, that's
an interesting question.
I'll tell the truth.
It's something that I think we have mixed
feelings about.
And when I say we, I mean the Android organization
in general.
We want people to bring all of the best content
on Android.
At the same time, we don't want to just see
random crummy ports.
We wanna see things that are built for Android.
And for its unique abilities.
So that said, it's not very difficult to port
and open GLES game that's written in C to
Android.
There are some issues.
A lot of people think that since Android is
Linux, it should be very easy to port any
piece of Linux software.
And that's not entirely true.
Because Android like all other Linux systems
is build out of a lot of different components.
And there are some things you can pick and
choose in terms of the libraries, internal
chains.
We have a specific C runtime that we use called
bionic.
That a lot of other people don't use.
And all of this adds up to more hassle.
Now, normally for a Linux system this isn't
a hassle because you use something like apt
or you know, macports or one of these things
that compiles everything and runs through
a bunch of compatibility scripts.
And if you've ever used a port system, you
know that there's like a million different
tasks to figure out where your C runtime lives.
And where your pilot lives and all these other
things.
Android of course doesn't do that.
We distribute binaries to the phone.
Or to the device.
So you are not able to count on all of the
things that your desktop Linux system has.
Or even all of the things that are in the
Android open source project right now.
What we do instead is we release something
called the NDK.
The native development kit.
There's a lot of things in the NDK.
But the real core of it, the irreplaceable
piece of it is a set of headers that form
a contract that Google has decided we will
always fulfill.
>>Dan g: Yeah, it has an NADI, an application
binary interface.
And the key thing about that is that for your
open GL calls, those open GL calls will be
essentially identical because open GL is a
standard.
It actually provides a contracted ABI itself.
And we're adhering to that contract.
So from an open GL perspective all the open
GL code should port over incredibly easily.
Obviously, if you're taking advantage of any
architecture specific implementation details,
especially extensions.
Those'll have to be looked at.
But the vast majority of the open GL code
will run absolutely identically on both platforms.
>>Ian: You will need to be aware of one thing
though.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: Which is because Android is an open
system, there's a huge number of OEMs.
You can't make as many assumptions about the
GPU hardware as you can with some other systems.
>>Dan g: Absolutely.
>>Ian: So even though the open GLES ABI is
standard, some of the extensions that you
may have come to rely on or possibly some
of the behaviors or even bugs that you may
rely on one system are not necessarily going
to be the same on other systems.
A good example of that is that PVR GPUs do
geometry sorting.
So they're almost completely insensitive to
the way you submit geometry.
But they are very sensitive to how many state
transitions you do.
>>Dan G: yes.
>>Ian: Where as Tegra GTUs are almost the
opposite.
They change state very fast but you want to
always sort front to back.
>>Dan G: exactly and so the real key, and
that's certainly, it's only one issue.
There's also things like if you wanna use
texture compression.
You know, there is not a standard.
>>Ian: Everybody's got their own thing.
>>Dan G: High performance ones used on Android,
there's also you know, there are also issues
in terms of how you should write your shaders.
And you know, making sure that you're really
querying very carefully.
Also making sure that you do test those shaders
on a variety of GPUs. 'cause you will see
different performance cliffs from device to
device.
That being said, from a coding perspective,
your code is going to, what you really have
to look at is audio 'cause the audio standards
are very very different.
You're gonna look at touch and events which
Networking actually if you're not using SSL,
you can just use sockets.
And so your socket code will come over pretty
much straight, to be honest.
So there's a lot you do get a lot.
You can actually use even threading you can.
If you're using standard p-threads.
If you, as long as you're not relying on making
calls back into the Dalvik virtual machine
you can actually use those very easily.
Or you can actually tie those back into Dalvik
threads.
And there's actually a really nice library
that Invidia has provided for doing that.
So there really are a lot of things you can
do and really one of the main reasons we do
the NDK is to allow people to take advantage
of tested code sections that you, code libraries.
That you have a written for another platform.
So from that perspective, that plus the standard
APIs do provide a really nice basis.
Especially for games.
Where it gets more challenging is when you
want to take advantage of the Android standard
UI patterns.
And those are, there's a lot of useful stuff
in there.
Even if it comes to things like font rendering.
Database storage isn't there.
So if you wanna use databases you're gonna
have to make a call through JNI to getó
>>Ian: Oh, no, no.
You're gonna get to make a call through JNI.
>>Dan G: [chuckles] That's right.
>>Ian: Because remember the java interfaces
in Android are very very easy to use compared
to C and C++.
There's' a lot fewer ways to shoot yourself
in the foot.
You'll end up writing a lot less code.
A good example of this is when you're doing
your game play, you know, every large scale
C++ project that I've worked on has its own
resource management and reflection system.
Which of course is built into Dalvik and into
the java framework.
So you can actually save yourself a lot of
time.
Especially when you're dealing with platform
specific things.
But even when you're not, by going into Dalvik
or another virtual machine.
>>Dan G: Absolutely.
And there's plenty of places even in a game
where it makes a lot of sense to take advantage
of Android framework resources.
Things like notifications for example.
You know, networking.
It's just nice to take advantage of the built
in HTP stack.
Built in SSL implementation.
All that kinda stuff.
So there is a bunch of stuff that it does
make sense to actually move code over to the
Dalvik virtual machine.
But that being said, for your core code, if
there's things like physics engines that may
be written entirely in native code.
Things like box td.
There's really no reason not to just use that
code as it is.
If it's a well-tested bit of code.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
OK.
I think that's enough on that.
Producer Reto, are there any more questions?
>>Reto: No.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan G: Excellent.
[laughs] [inaudible]
>>Ian: Well done on the producer cam.
That isó
>>Dan G: We're getting the hang of that today.
>>Ian: Yes.
Good job.
>>Dan G: That's awesome.
>>Ian: Now, we're running a little low on
time but something occurs to me which is that
we did not actually go in order of what people
voted one today.
>>Dan G: That's true.
>>Ian: We sort of went in order of what we
personally thought was cool.
Especially in order of these big profitable
games.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: Which I think makes us look a lot like
tools of the game oligopoly establishment.
>>Dan G: Well, and I will say that all of
these games really are fun, like these are
great games.
>>Ian: Yeah, absolutely.
There's no question about that.
>>Dan G: And they're beautiful.
They make, they makeó
>>Ian: But again, we don't wanna be tools.
>>Dan G: No that's true.
And actually I didn't, I would have added
Need For Speed: Hot Pursuit by the way, to
this list, had I been a tool.
Because I actually love Need for Speed: Hot
Pursuit.
I have ever since it came out.
>>Ian: I don't think it's a tool thing to
beó
>>Dan G: And but I didn't nominate it to the
list because there were so many other big
games on the list already.
So let's--
>>Ian: Well, my main point is, we need to
look at Tractor Digger.
>>Dan G: So Tractor Digger is not actually
a racing game.
>>Ian: It's not.
>>Dan G: So I'm just going to bring it up
very very quickly.
>>Ian: But it was voted number one.
[inaudible]
>>Dan G: It was voted number one.
And it is built using AndEngine.
>>Ian: and by the way you know who else is
a tool?
Anybody who watches this show and doesn't
vote.
Vote for stuff.
>>Dan G: So this is actually a puzzle game
and your goal is to move things into the tractor.
You've got a dual joystick control.
And then we can actually take this stuff and
move it into this dumpster here.
And it's actually pretty cool.
It is not [chuckles] a racing game.
>>Ian: We didn't say racing game.
We said driving game.
Are you driving?
>>Dan G: Sort of.
>>Ian: Are you driving a tractor?
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: I think you're driving a tractor.
Um, now for some reason Dan is snapping his
fingers at us and I don't know why.
>>Dan G: Ah, the reason why is that I don't
have this tablet plugged in.
so let's actually show you what I was doing
rather than have me just looking down.
>>Ian: Yeah, see that's why we look at the
monitor.
>>Dan G: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: And not the, yeah.
>>Dan G: That's why we have that.
That's a good point.
So anyways, oh it's backwards though.
That's really hard.
[laughs] Never mind.
>>Ian: Maybe just glance at it.
But--[inaudible]
>>Dan g: Yeah, exactly.
So, um, so we can actually take advantage
of physics here to scoop up the rock into
our little tractor and then we can actually
flip it all the way round to the other side
in order to dump it back into the dumpster.
But it is a puzzler game.
And it's cool.
You're driving a tractor.
And it's something I haven't seen before.
It's an AndEngine game.
Which is always nice to see.
If you haven't actually used AndEngine before
it is a really nice 2D game development platform.
Written for Android.
We actually have them showing off the tools
chain at Google IO this year.
And it really does look, it looks nice.
And they're doing a lot of investment in it.
Which is exciting.
Oh by the way, you're not trying to get the
boulders into the truck.
Just.
Uh.
>>Ian: I did a good job of it though.
>>Dan G: Yes you did, you did.
Now, at the controls.
The controls work well, there's definitely
some parts of this game where I want to see
higher resolution artwork.
Some more work done on some of the textures.
So that it looks less this sort of repeating
pattern that you're seeing at the bottom.
It just screams "I'm tiling something!"
>>Ian: Right.
The right way to do that by the way is to
create three or four random textures and just
randomize them.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: For a texture like this, you can use,
there's actually some photoshop plugins that
do this.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: You get something that has four or
five different textures but they all tile
seamlessly along the edges.
>>Dan G: Mm-hm.
>>Ian: And then you just pick 'em at random
and it looks really good.
>>Dan G: It really does.
And that same thing I would say with the grass
texture.
It's just like, tile, tile, tile, tile, tile.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan G: And I would love to see a little
bit of work.
'cause there's so much work that actually
went into the vehicles in this game.
>>Ian: Yeah, they're cool.
And you know what, I dig the background in
this game even though it's just a photo.
Its' nice that it's out of focus.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: It's got that depth of field effect
to it.
Good job there.
>>Dan G: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: OK.
Let's move on.
>>Dan G: Let's move on.
Again, not a, not a racing game.
Another one that's in the category of somewhat--
>>Ian: [whispering off mic]
>>Dan G: Somewhat smaller games is Drag Racing
from Nitro Nation.
>>Ian: I really like this game.
>>Dan G: And um, this game was, is kind of
fun.
but it really just seemed to be an exercise
in trying to end up getting me to buy stuff.
Which was a little unfortunate.
You know, its' like, what I found was that
pretty much no matter how well I did in the
game, if I did not have a car that was good
enough and this was not an example of that.
I was just going to lose.
Mostly because it's just kind of minimal controls
here.
And I actually played this game not particularly
well.
I should actually be shifting.
>>Ian: I was gonna say, you know.
>>Dan G: See, you get good shifts.
>>Ian: If you shift like a moron you're not
gonna get anything out of the race.
>>Dan g: Yeah, but even if you shift really
really well, you know, there's a point at
which your car just isn't good enough.
And you'll have to buy a new car.
And the only way to buy a new car is to get
respect.
And it's very challenging to get respect within
the game without actually paying money.
And I kinda wish the game had sort of a deeper
grind factor.
Maybe it's there and I just didn't see it.
>>Ian: Mm-hm.
>>Dan G: In my playing of the game.
That being said, the game plays really well.
It looks pretty good.
A little tiny bit blurry here on the size
of a Transformer Prime.
>>Ian: It's definitely a button masher.
>>Dan G: It's, I wouldn't sayó
>>Ian: Yeah, it'só
>>Dan G: I wouldn't even call it a masher.
>>Ian: It's Pavlovian.
It shows you the little upshift thing and
then you press the button and it says "Good
job!"
>>Dan G: Exactly.
>>Ian: Good Job!
>>Dan G: So yeah, it's pretty limited.
But I wanted to at least bring it up.
You know, and again, if you like this kinda
game, it seems to be a pretty good version
of that, of an entry into that genre.
>>Ian: I mean, I've seen better.
I really have.
But not on tablet.
>>Dan G: exactly.
Now another completely different kind of racing
game is Reckless Get Away.
>>Ian: Oh, this is a great game.
I love this.
>>Dan G: This is a super fun. it's, and it
actually has a cute little story behind it
that you are trying to get away.
Let's actually doó
>>Ian: Recklessly?
>>Dan G: Recklessly.
Yeah.
And even little details like.
>>Ian: I love that.
"Please wait, robbery in progress."
That's a great one.
>>Dan G: Robbery in progress.
I love the money flying out of your car.
There's all sorts of cool jumps you can take.
There is just tons and tons and tons of stuff
to do in this game.
>>Ian: Now I would have loved to have a little
bit more control over it.
but maybe that's just me.
Now I'm old and I don't have the greatest
reflexes, but I felt like this control scheme
was actually really difficult to manage.
I would have actually liked some really sensitive
tilt controls.
Which is odd because as you know, I hate tilt
controls.
But--
>>Dan G: Yeah, driving games are one of the
few places
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan G: In which I find that tilt controls
actually are not so bad.
And I often prefer them.
>>Ian: Well especially if they're reasonably
sensitive.
>>Dan G: But this game is really well done.
And it's, I love the perspective.
You know, we took a jump there.
>>Ian: and all the background work they've
done.
I mean this is, it's a professional title.
There's no question about that.
>>Dan G: Yeah, absolutely.
So I mean as I said, I was glad to see this
up there.
This game hasn't gotten a lot of love recently
and I think it's just, I think it's a really
well done title that does something substantially
different in this genre.
You know.
There's really what I, three different kinds
of games that we see really commonly in the
genre.
We see sort of slot racing games.
Which are over the head where you see a large
percentage of the track.
We see the more traditional driving games.
And this is a perspective we don't see nearly
as much.
Which is kind of reminiscent of the perspective
from like Spy Hunter.
In the original overheadó
>>Ian: that is what it reminds me of.
Yeah.
>>Dan G: Overhead racing game.
And it's awesome.
>>Ian: [inaudible]
>>Dan G: So you know, I definitely, here's
by the way an example of the developer who
just did not know what to do with the back
key.
Here we are we've got a screen that says "Play
again" and "Continue" and there, so what do
we do here with the back key.
Well actually in this particular case, Play
again or Continue, there is actually a third
option which would be Exit to the main menu.
And hitting the back key actually should exit
you back here.
There's no reason why it needs to be Play
and Continue.
This is sort of a design, so they made the
back key do nothing.
That's bad.
It should always do something.
Especially at the end of the game when you
might just wanna exit.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan G: And switch game modes and instead
you have to target the continue button which
is really unfortunate.
>>Ian: Remember, the back button does two
things.
It moves you back to the previous activity.
Or it dismisses dialogs.
So if you're saying to yourself, "Wow, what
I'm looking at here has no meaningful back
thing."
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: you know maybe it's because you need
to think of it as a dismissing rather than
a moving on.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
Continue actually does not.
When I saw "continue", I think what does continue
mean?
I had no idea.
And then I realized what they, what "continue"
actually does is take you back to the selection
screen.
So "continue" is really not, doesn't make
much sense there.
>>Ian: It's tough.
Certainly there are some places where we stretch
a little bit.
But you know what?
Suck it up.
Android has a back button and people expect
to be able to use it.
>>Dan G: So here's I wanted to bring up Tiny
Little Racing.
>>Ian: Oh yeah, you know what, we were gonna
look at this a while ago.
And then we didn't.
>>Dan G: So first of alló
>>Ian: And I even said "Wow, we really loved
this."
And it turned out I was wrong.
>>Dan G: [laughs]
>>Ian: It turned out it was a different game
with a really really similar name that we
really really loved.
But this is still a good game.
>>Dan G: So let's talk about it.
First of all, we see this.
>>Ian: Oooohh.
Don't.
>>Dan G: [shouting] Don't ever do this!
>>Ian: Yeah, yeah.
>>Dan G: Don't ever do this because weó
>>Ian: At least autofill, come on.
>>Dan G: Well it's not just that.
One is that I'm not using the standard Android
keyboard.
>>Ian: Oh yeah.
>>Dan G: So the question is, I'm gonna stick
this in the dock.
And the keyboard doesn't work.
>>Ian: [shouting] Number two!
Camera two!
>>Dan G: Go to switch to camera two!
>>Ian: Number two!
Camera two?
>>Dan: Wreee!
Wreee!
No, that's a no!
>>Ian: [inaudible] Alright.
OK.
Now look at what poor Dan is trying to do
here.
>>Dan G: Yeah, I'm, I just quit the game.
But I was trying to type my name. and I can't
type on the keyboard.
>>Ian: The point is, he's just amazingly frustrated
with this whole thing.
[loud tapping sound]
>>Dan G: Because we're not using one of the
default input methods of Android so I can't
actually type my name using the keyboard that's
in front of me!
So this is, so don't use your own input method
as a general rule, even though it looks really
cool.
And you can put Comic Sans on there.
Which also I say never use Comic Sans.
But that's a different question.
>>Ian: Yeah, did you not get the meme?
[laughter]
>>Dan G: So.
So that's one thing.
This game is fun.
I definitely wanna see some higher resolution
graphics.
Everything here is really really blurry.
>>Ian: Yeah, this game wasn't really built
for a tablet.
>>Dan G: No.
>>Ian: Also the models are really low res.
So you get the feeling that maybe this was
tuned for a much less capable device.
And that's fine.
But what you might wanna do and this is just
a general game design idea, in general, it's
not very difficult to make a model that's
very high polygon count.
I mean, the hard part is reducing it to a
low polygon count.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: So if you keep your sources and just
every now and then when the state of technology
gets there, put some better models in your
game.
>>Dan G: Yeah, actually to be honest, the
models I think the car models are really good.
It's the rest of everything else that I want
to see.
>>Ian: Well, the car models are attractive.
My point is that they're low poly.
>>Dan G: Yeah, and then they don't really
look like anything else in the game.
And I think it's cute some of the design elements.
But I would love to see some, even if the
backgrounds are gonna look like that it'd
be kind of cool if they were a little bit
soft focused that kind of thing.
>>Ian: Now let's just move to camera two really
quick.
You'll notice that my excessively large hands
still have to kind of reach to get theó
>>Dan G: Yes.
Sorry.
We're losing HD Mic here.
>>Ian: Yeah, left and right button there.
I mean, there, it really is a stretch.
Notó
>>Dan G: This is an example of buttons that
are not scaled based upon the pixel density
of the screen.
They're stretched based upon the screen size.
So we have two options here.
One is that we can look at pixel density.
That helps a little bit.
The other thing is we actually can have a
separate tablet layout that would help even
more.
>>Ian: Yeah, remember that Android has some
really nice features for putting together
layouts of different screens.
And a lot of game developers say "Well that
doesn't affect me at all.
Because I'm not making views and I'm not making
horizontal layout."
>>Dan G: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: But you know what?
You don't have to use that for just views
or dialog designs or UI designs.
What you can do is put constant values in
there.
And then pull those out based on the resource
id.
And you'll get the different values based
on which screen size you're on.
Or you know, whatever you filter it on.
>>Dan G: Absolutely.
And again you could do a couple things.
One is you could actually get the pixel density.
And you can just apply that to what you're
doing in open GL.
So you're getting some thing that's the correct
physical size.
Which is really important.
'Cause what you wanna make sure is also if
this screen were very very small you'd still
want those things to be very very large.
And this things looks like it's just stretching
based on the size of the screen.
So that's definitely one thing.
Making it automatic is really important too.
So--
>>Ian: Yeah, one thing you can do actually
in open GL that's really super cool is define
your UI in meters.
Which sounds stupid.
But trust me.
Don't ever do-- Like I've been on projects
where people like, "Oh, maybe we want a little
bit more precision or whatever.
Let's use decimeters or something."
>>Dan G: Exactly.
>>Ian: And it just screws up your physics
system.
Don't ever use that.
But define your UI in meters and then just
have a matrix that scales from meters to screen
units.
>>Dan G: and you'll definitely have to test
this on a wide variety of physical screen
sizes.
But it's much much easier than actually trying
to come up with lots and lots of individual
layouts to handle every single setup.
Every single combination of pixel and density.
>>Ian: and I'm not gonna lie to you.
This isn't easy.
There is no simple thing that you can to.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: Especially if you're dealing with different
aspect ratios.
But it will be worth it.
>>Dan G: Yeah, I mean, you know, the key thing
is, if you're trying to make the HUD look
super attractive and perfect.
It's definitely a bunch of work.
>>Ian: Oh yeah.
Your artists who, I'll tell you exactly what
they're gonna say.
They're gonna be like "We have to be pixel
perfect."
>>Dan G: Yeah.
>>Ian: Otherwise it's no good.
And that actually is, I said I would never
swear on this show.
It is not true.
>>Dan G: [laughs] Very good.
That was well, I knew, I heard it coming.
And I heard like, there's, the yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: But lemme tell you why it's not true.
So that was extremely true back when we were
working with NTSC TVs, or 480P. or even the,
you know, a really high resolution on a big
screen.
>>Dan g: but today everything is bi-linear
filtered.
At least get tható
>>Ian: Well not only that.
But also we're talking about these really
really dense displays.
OK, fine.
If you're supporting some random old thing
that has a very low density display.
You might want to think about this really
carefully.
Butó
>>Dan G: Here's an example.
Let's take a look at Nexus 7.
>>Ian: You just can't tell.
>>Dan G: Nexus 7.
All of the icons you see here for every single
app are actually being scaled down.
>>Ian: Mm-hm.
>>Dan G: We did not actually come up with
new icons for every single app at this pixel
density.
Because, you knowó
>>Ian: Right, this is a 213 dpi.
And we scaled from what, 250, or something?
220?
>>Dan G: Yeah.
And, 240.
>>Ian: 240, right.
>>Dan G: and so we're scaling down a small
fraction.
Honestly on this high of a pixel density display
you don't even notice it most of the time.
You can actually go and create icons at 213
dpi if you want to.
But we looked at it and we said, it's just
not worth it.
And so it think that says a lot about scaling
down.
If you're even, and again, icons are the worst
thing you can scale typically.
Because they're really really information
dense.
>>Ian: Except for text.
>>Dan G: Except for text.
But even icons, a lot of icons contain text.
And a lot of icons contain line art.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan G: And details that you would normally
think, oh this shouldn't scale.
And the realityó
>>Ian: Don't put that in your iPods.
>>Dan G: Yeah.
The reality is, that, and actually let's take
one last look at the tablet.
I wanted to look at the icons today.
>>Ian: We are five minutes over time and Producer
Reto is like packing up his stuff.
>>Dan G: [laughs]
>>Ian: And ready to go.
>>Dan G: So just one thing out of all these
icons.
There are two icons that actually I think
are reasonable Android icons.
That is the tractor digger icon believe it
or not.
And the GTA icon.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan G: Every single one of those.
>>Ian: Everyone looks like it's been maybe
lifted from somebody else's design.
>>Dan G: Yeah, yeah, come on guys.
Let's, let's try to make things.
Every one of those looks the same, it's hard
to actually differentiate the content of all
those other ones.
But Tractor Digger and GTA are really easy
to differentiate.
>>Ian: Also I'm just gonna say, Asphalt 7,
the game left icon looks like a six.
It looks a lot like a six.
It looks like Asphalt 7 6.
I'm just saying.
Alright, so let's go ahead andó
Dan G: Next, so yeah.
Everyone make sure to vote next week.
That's what I wantedó
>>Ian: Yeah, so next week's apps areó
>>Dan G: Sports!
Because it's the Olympics.
Exactly.
>>Ian: Will have been the Olympics.
>>Dan G: Yes.
>>Ian: So really it's sports games next week.
Now if you don't know how this works, you
go to our page at Developers.Google.com slash
live.
Which is not down in the corner because this
is the wrong title.
But it will be.
Or you know, the link will always be in the
event that we put on our Google plus page.
At that link, developer.Android.com slash
plus.
Go there and there is at the very bottom,
scroll down to the bottom.
Ignore the big black video thing that doesnít
have anything in it because there is no video
yet.
Ignore that.
Scroll down.
Scroll down further.
[Dan laughing]
Then at the bottom of the page there is a
Moderator link.
It's actually not a link.
It's actually embedded because the people
that did it are really cool web people.
It's embedded in the page and you can suggest
new apps.
Or new games.
>>Dan G: Yes.
You can flip to the tablet if you want to
see what this looks like.
>>Ian: And you can also vote for the ones
that you really like it.
Yeah yeah.
Exactly.
>>Dan G: So I put this up on our tablet.
You can see everything we've looked at.
You can see we now are looking at Sports games.
For next time.
And right now, we already have our first suggestions.
Some of which don't look like sports games.
>>Ian: Yeah, exactly.
So "Hi, when do you plan to review puzzle
games."
Not next week.
So let's do that somewhere else.
>>Dan G: [laughs] Yes.
>>Ian: This will be marked as "Inappropriate."
Let's flag that as "Inappropriate."
But thanks.
Because we do love puzzle games.
At some point it'll happen.
Just stay tuned.
Just keep watching the show.
>>Dan G: Exactly.
So stay tuned.
>>Ian: If you donít watch the show every
week, how are you gonna know?
>>Dan G: Right.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan G: So definitely continue to nominate,
continue to vote.
We're really excited about a lot of what we
saw this week.
And I'm looking forward to seeing some great
sports games.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Dan G: And golf is a sport.
So if you want toó
>>Ian: Mmmmm-kay.
>>Dan G: As an example.
So we're thinking about things, I want mostly
things that are a lot of Olympic sports too.
If there is something good that we've missed
and it doesn't have to be summer Olympics.
>>Ian: Oh yeah.
If there's a great dressage app out there,
I wanna see it.
[Dan laughs]
But the other thing that I wanna remind you
is our goal here is to help developers make
better games.
So we may not always review the most popular
games.
We may not always be kind to some games.
But our goal is to at least help you understand
how a game could be better.
Now sometimes we don't accomplish that because
the game is so great to begin with Radiant
Defense.
But.
[Dan laughs]
IN general if we're critical of a game it's
'cause we think it's decent but could be better.
And for that reason actually our colleague
Reto has renamed his show "The Friday App
Clinic."
>>Dan G: Mmm.
>>Ian: We may do something similar.
I don't know.
Leave a comment on our G plus page.
>>Dan G: Exactly.
Let us know exactly.
>>Ian: OK, we gotta get out of here.
>>Dan G: We're way over time.
>>Ian: We're way over time.
>>Dan G: We started late though.
So it's, we can be a little over.
>>Ian: So thanks once again to our producer
Reto Meier.
Our engineer Daniel Fam.
And we will see you next week.
>>Dan G: Cheers.
[bottles clink]